sameer do you make movies because you
love the process or because you have to
just asking really interesting questions
in the first place I always thought I i
love filmmaking you know when I remember
how I I went into this business I I
remember I was only one year at the art
school and they told me I have to go for
drawing or for photography and I refused
I thought drawing is I was excellent so
I was I thought this is boring to be to
be alone to be alone you know and
photograph I missed I thought that's so
stupid did you know the world is moving
why should that take only a picture so i
decided to go and make an apprenticeship
as a type of graph because i loved
typography typography in general and
writings and you see that in my films
all of them are full with with any
alphabet and words because i believe
words are are like there-there are not
only graphics there if you if you use
the right types you you create an image
which is much more important than only
the meaning of the world however I
understood then that I i love much more
to work with people and so i worked as a
laborer
in the factory and I loved it very much
because to create things together with
other humans each I think this is them
the most beautiful process and that's
why we are humans I believe that
strongly so of course there are
exceptions great writers great painters
whatever but in generally I believe I'm
more that type and so it was naturally
that out of my interest I found my way
into this business and in the first
place I wanted really to create things
together with others I became a member
of a video collective in Zurich and we
worked or everything together until you
know after five years I find out that I
had I had more ideas to express things
than others which might more be much
more interested in you no lights or
camera techniques or whatever but we had
the strong idea you know as a corporate
group that we should do things all
together so that was the moment where I
understood that I'm also driven by
formal aspects you know of how creating
things and how each they should look so
my first film I made with this group
together but I lead them to create my
own movies and they were at that time
all of them have the experimental stuff
and it was very very unique i didn't
knew that I'm doing something unique
until you know the art museum started to
buy my stuff then I felt how okay it has
some importance but I I was not driven
by that and I didn't like the idea that
I should be in in a ivory tower
of art you know so so end of the 80s I
left it and I i went to to work with
with the TV on popular cinema stuff you
know until i created than my own company
yeah so it's i'm driven by my own
obsession that's for sure and in the
same time I love to work with people
together it's you know I was a radical
you saw in my film and I still believe
that humans should work together and
equal even if they are diverse
you